Thì mình ai phong tổ chức sự kiện giảm mắt tân câu vụ khuy,
sáng lại 1 mốt tham người,
ở mốn trong khách hàng đất em giả sự kiện giảm mắt tân câu vụ khuy của dự án vì
lạc tà.
Thì người, trong công sang gatord mang tên hóa phòng mãi sau.
Sức kênh mờ mang mang chiến trạm vào mình đất vụ khuy, lời tin nhìn,
anh sáng và tâm gì con người hoặc về tàng một bức quá nả sát.
Bà sống cân với bà phòng cách sống, hại bình thông, sĩnh này chương hôm,
và giả hôm, tự tayyền sống động qua em nhạc, anh sáng và trình dính nghệ thuật.
Phần trình dính của các c xí và mời hưởng,
hẹp lại trong bàn buổi sáng nằm lượng bà cảm hướng.
Tổ chồng sự kiện, một trong các hàng đất em,
cho mất tân hồ khuy của bý, đánh nhìn qua tạm ai phong,
mùi bệ trộ mắc, ai chăm năm sau vì các bạn.
Vì lạc tà, khi mình thấy em kìm năng đầu tư khi hồ tổ đồ vị chiến lợc,
hát tăng đâm bò, pháp lý bứng phản, kìa lấy quan trình.